comme l'ensemble des secteurs les
banques ont elles aussi été frappée par
la crise qualifiée de services
essentiels
elles ont été contraints de s'adapter à
la nouvelle réalité de pandémie en
augmentant leurs services en ligne entre
autres alors à quoi ça va ressembler les
banques de demain est ce qu on pourrait
même penser à la fin des succursales
bancaires
on en parle avec celui de maire c'est le
président du groupe banque td québec
merci d'être là madame demers et
acidification vous avez bon plusieurs
années d'expérience vous travaillez le
domaine bancaire depuis longtemps vous
avez connu plusieurs crises le lundi
noir d'octobre 1987 en bourse la crise
financière en quoi la crise actuelle est
différente
écoutez je crois que ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui c'est une crise financière
mais ses grands-mères accentuée par
l'insécurité pis l'anxiété de la crise
sanitaire
alors ça bouge dans les anciennes qui
dans les crimes de 2002 conventionnés il
y avait là il ya des pays qui est
impactée plus que d'autres alors sur les
entreprises quelquefois fait naviguer
dans ça aujourd'hui on parle de
problèmes planétaires la planète entière
a été mis sur pause et il y avait aussi
évidemment le virus qui crée même
énormément d'entités autant chez les les
dans les entreprises que dans les
succursales bancaires
des employés étaient des revues au début
et puis je pense que c'est là si c'était
cette salle était accentuée crise la
crise financière a été accentuée par
tous et incertitudes
ce côté de la santé de quelle manière
madame le maire de la pandémie va forcer
les institutions financières les banques
à changer les façons travail dans les
succursales mais écoutez ça on n'a pas
eu le choix parce que il doit il fallait
évidemment s'harmoniser à toutes les
normes
sanitaires les nomme d'urgence sanitaire
du gouvernement
on devait assurer une distanciation
physique les succursales on a réduit le
nombre de succursales ouvertes
on a diminué les arts on a dû mettre en
place comme je le disais beaucoup
d'hommes pour la distanciation refermer
le virtuel madame le maire absolument
alors du côté des services virtuels
beaucoup de d'éducation et de conseil
pour nos employés pour nos clients
certains ont toujours été réfractaire et
aujourd'hui vont ils ne voulaient pas se
présenter en sus cure faire les horizons
à qu'ils ont dû adopter certains de ces
services là c'est certain que cela était
nécessaire et on a vu dans les derniers
trois mois à la td vie dans l'industrie
financière en général un mouvement
beaucoup plus rapide de nouveaux de
nouvelles applications pour rendre la
vie plus facile à nos clients tout en
faisant les fractions ce que c'est moins
les transactions d'une manière
sécuritaire
l'ange la sécurité quand même important
ici parce que on se demandait ce que
c'est plus risqué par exemple or pour la
sécurité même pour identifier la
personne qui est au bout de l'écran on
sait qu'une augmentation des froids ou
de l'an cette période de pandémie
vous avez été en mesure d'assurer la
future république processus l'air mal à
la fraude est toujours été au coeur de
nos préoccupations puis on n'a fait
aucun compromis pour nos proches soient
dans nos procédures de si tu étais à la
td on a toujours accordé énormément
d'importance à la confiance que nos
clients témoigne la protection des
données à l'art d'ailleurs on a de grâce
à la vigilance d'un foyer d'une de nos
succursales en haillons nos permis
d'éviter une fraude de 45 millions $
bon alors sa forme le fonctionner ce que
vous avez mis en place mais la question
qu'on se pose c'est vous avez parlé de
moins du kursaal ouvertes des arts et du
et des services virtuels quelle part de
ces changements là qui ont été implantés
par an pendant la pandémie est là pour
rester mais écoutez je vous dirais
que les clients auront adopté certains
services et apprécié ces services là à
là ça va rester on nous avons aussi mis
en place pour récupérer des dans le fond
là les enregistrements mobile à l'entrée
des succursales pour que les clients
puissent avec leur téléphone cellulaire
s'inscrire dans une une ligne virtuelle
si vous voulez donc il n'était pas plus
d'où le besoin de rentrer à l'est ce que
ça nous attendre à l'extérieur montant
il pouvait faire d'autres courses soit
des choses comme ça alors ça c'est pour
rester parce que le client aujourd'hui
est occupée il est alors et pourrait
intervenir en succursale prend deux
rendez vous virtuel et on la vit qu'un
bientôt quand son rendez-vous va être
qu'un renvoi est disponible pour le
servir dans mesrine bien mais est ce que
tout ça peut même menacer l'existence
des succursales bancaires le service
d'une personne à l'autre est ce que ça
va réfléchir alors écouté personne n'a
de boule de cristal ce que je vous
dirais c'est toutes nos études avant la
pandémie nous démontrait que malgré
l'accélération des plates formes mobiles
l'utilisation des plateformes mobiles en
général la plupart des clients avaient
visité une succursale dans les derniers
91e embarquerez le fait qu'ils
utilisaient les les plateformes mobiles
parce qu'il ya une différence en faire
une transaction qui est récurrente que
qui est facile qui se fait via mobile
mais le contact humain et le conseil
personnalisé
je continue à croire que c'est surtout
pour les dix plus complet que le départ
était là dessus madame demers mais ce
que je comprends c'est que vous y croyez
encore je remercie ma couverture très
bien merci beaucoup bonne soirée